now listen to yuval ravani uh from
hebrew university
about more mixtures
so uh i'll talk about uh joint work with
uh spencer gordon bijan mazahiri and
leonard chulman from all of them from
caltech and all of them here in the
audience
actually
same same area
more or less
um
okay so i'm i'm going to uh this talk is
really a continuation of leonard stock
uh
it's part of our ongoing uh
research project uh
that has so far yielded some results
uh so i'll reiterate some of the
introduction that leonard gave uh
perhaps with somewhat different emphasis
um so i'll start by reminding everyone
what's a bayesian network uh something i
guess all of you know but just to be on
the same page
uh so we have uh directed acyclic graph
g
the nodes of this graph are random
variables
and the joint distribution of
these random variables is
markovian with respect to the graph g
which means that uh you can factor
uh the joint distribution uh into a
product of um
uh distributions of the individual
variables conditioned on the values of
their parents
so here is an example of
some
bayesian network
and
we will use
the standard convention
that
solid
nodes and and edges indicate
uh
things that are observable
and
dotted uh
nodes are
confounding variables that are not
observable that we don't get to see in
our samples
um and i guess uh we'll use uh u's to
indicate the hidden variables and either
x or v to indicate the observable
uh variables
uh okay so so this notation uh
uh
small letters pa indicates a particular
assignment
to the parent set of a node x i
okay
here are some examples
um
i think leonard showed these examples
but i'll go over them
in a little bit more detail uh so so so
uh this particular uh
bayesian network is the setting that
leonard talked about uh we have a
confounding variable u and that affects
uh a bunch of
variables that conditioned on the
confounding variable are
independent
so that's the mix prod problem
this middle
example
is something i'm not going to talk about
but just uh
for the sake of uh
uh background uh this is uh called the
hidden markov model so uh we have a
chain
of uh hidden variables
and this chain simply represents uh uh
what happens when uh you uh run a markov
chain for for n steps so the initial
uh u1 is just the distributed on the
um
state space of the markov chain
according to the initial distribution
and then uh
you take one step and you get u2 and and
so forth so so this is just a run on the
markov chain but you don't get to see
the actual uh states of the markov chain
what you get to see are measurements of
uh each of the states so uh the
observables are uh
some measurements of the hidden states
and they're otherwise independent
so any dependence is from the hidden
part in this case and and this is a
model that we will not talk about
but the bottom model
is is uh an example of what we will talk
about
so um here we have some
uh
some
uh observable
uh network and in this case the
observable network is is is actually a a
markov
model
but there is a confounding variable that
affects all of the states of this markov
model so what we get here is a mixture
of uh markov models
uh and and this is the type of uh of uh
bayesian networks that uh this talk will
will consider
uh so now i'll be a little bit more
specific what what is the setting that
that we're uh looking at
um
first of all
um we will assume
that the
uh
observable variables
are distributed in a finite set
and we can assume in fact without loss
of generality that they're all bernoulli
trials so so every observable variable
uh
get takes values which are either zero
or one
uh and this is without loss of
generality because a
larger finite sets can be reduced to
this uh
uh case and i won't go into that uh uh
thing it's it's a reduction that's been
um
explained in in quite a number of uh of
papers uh including our paper
um
now we're interested in identification
and what does identification mean it
means that we want the computer get it a
good estimate
of the unique probabilistic model
that explains the observed data
so uh
this is more than what you
normally want to do
when you learn leonard talked about this
about the difference between learning
and identification
learning just means that you want to
compute some probabilistic model that
explains the data
here we want to get
a good estimate in the parameter space
and um
therefore we need to assume that the
parameter space is unique or at least up
to some small tolerance is unique
because otherwise there will be
different
far apart models that explain the same
observable distribution
so one interpretation of the results
that we have is that we actually
establish conditions
uh
on the system that enable identification
because not every
um
setting will be identifiable
now the observations are
naturally
independent samples of the joint
distribution on
the
observed random variables so we don't
get to see the the hidden variable but
we do get to see the observed variables
and we get the sample from that joint
distribution uh as many times as we like
so so we want to bound the number of
samples that are needed
and we do assume that the uh actual
causal relations are known so we know
the graph
now uh the assumption is actually a
little bit weaker than this uh what we
really need is we need uh that the
actual graph
is a subset of of the graph that we're
given
so so so some of the edges that we are
given
uh may be
um you know not there uh there's no
there's no influence uh that's okay
now uh
of course uh there is
a natural graph if you ignore the
directions at least there is a natural
graph that you can always take which is
the complete graph
so that's not good enough because we
will see that the degree plays a role in
in this thing so so so we need some
uh
guess of the actual causal relations uh
that includes all the uh
all the real ones uh doesn't have to be
identical to the real ones but it
shouldn't emit any
uh possible causal relation that that
might exist
okay
um
now we're talking as i said about this
setting
which
these are mixture models there is a
single confounding variable u it affects
all the
observed variables
uh the graph g is known and we want to
identify the joint probability
distribution including the distribution
on u which we don't see
now in this generality
uh leonard already mentioned that
the problem is
is really
unsolvable because um
if you takes a very large
number of possible values you can
completely control
uh the distribution here so uh if you
don't make any assumptions on you you
can just output
this model where u takes uh an
exponential here exponential in 13 two
to the third 13 different values and
each of these values uh has a
probability which is exactly the
frequency in which uh this particular
output uh appears uh in in the sample
uh and this is a completely valid model
so so uh so
you know we're just ignoring all these
causal relations
um because everything is deterministic
after you determine you so so we need
some some assumption
and here are the
uh assumptions so so this is in fact a
list of sufficient conditions
all of these conditions are sufficient
in order to enable identification
they're not they're not
necessarily
necessary condition but they are
sufficient conditions
so uh the first uh assumption is that
we're going to restrict to the range of
u
so uh we have a mixture of uh yes
yeah g is just the solid edges
so so u uh is sort of an additional
thing that we don't see
yeah so so g is just the solid edges
um okay so so the first assumption is
that you uh takes uh a range in a small
set
of size k i mean k will be the our
notation for the size of the set
um
and uh this means that uh if i look at
the graph g as a bayesian network so so
so every value of u uh there is some uh
uh bayesian network distribution on on
the network on the network g that we're
given and this and the whole model is a
mixture of k
bayesian network distributions so this
is the model that we're trying to learn
we'll denote by wj the probability that
u uh
gets value j
uh so this
the jth uh component of the mixture uh
pij will denote uh actually i'm not sure
i need that but uh i need it just here
uh so you can you can forget it after
the slide p i j is the probability that
v i equals one given that u
uh equals j
and n is um the number of observed
random variables it's just the size of g
the number of nodes in g
now
uh
you'll notice that uh if g is very small
for instance if n equals one if if we
only see one node
one observed node
the only thing we can learn is the
expectation
uh sorry it's i mean i meant here the
probability that v one equals one which
is the expectation of v one
um
so
um so so we can't really learn much
about the model
because uh even
uh the the the actual correct
description of how
uh v1 is generated
uh has two k minus one degrees of
freedom it's it's it's the uh weights of
the cons of the constituents of the
mixture and uh the uh one probabilities
for each of these constituents
so so so by looking at a tiny network
we're not going to be able uh to uh
identify the model so we need g to be
sufficiently large
now uh
another problem is if two different
values of u produce exactly the same
distribution
then of course we can't distinguish this
model from a model that has
uh fewer constituents
uh so so we need some assumption and the
assumption that we will use is is
similar to the separation assumption uh
that uh um appeared in leonard's talk so
so we we will assume that we have
sufficiently many uh zeta separated or
uh something zeta informative i won't
define this precisely but we actually
need this uh somewhat stronger notion
and you will see
roughly what it means as we go along
so so so we need some separation
condition on the observable variables
that they take distinct values for uh
different uh values of u
uh this is the assumption
zeta separation just means this
uh but we need this somewhat stronger
condition of zeta and formative
now uh from uh the lower bounds that
leonard mentioned uh we need at least
two k minus one zeta separated observed
uh variables this is a lower bound that
comes from even from the simplest
uh case of uh mix iid
and in general again from uh following
leonard's talk uh you need at least 2k
minus one zero separated observed
observables
uh in order to do
to to to identify even in an information
theoretic sense uh here we're talking
about an algorithmic sense
okay so so uh
these are the problems that uh yeah uh
go back to the previous slide sure to
clarify what do you mean here are you
saying that you need at least two k
minus one zeta separated observed
variables but you can also handle other
variables that are zero separated
uh yes
yes so in fact leonard didn't go into
this but uh
even for mixed prod you don't need all
the variables to be uh separated you
just needed the uh
for the algorithm that he mentioned you
needed three k minus three zeta
separated variables the rest don't need
to be zeta separate and the structure of
the graph over the observables doesn't
somehow there's no interplay between
that uh here it will play uh but in
letter spot there was no graph so uh so
it was uh uh so so obviously the
non-existent graph didn't play around
okay
um
so so uh leonard mentioned mick's iiv
and mixed fraud i i just listed here uh
a summary of the results that that he
already
uh stated
um
now here is uh
uh so so so we're going to focus on
on this result on mix uh
on the mixture of bayesian network
distributions
the general case
and what we're going to show
is in fact that uh this
problem reduces to a mixed product
so so we can solve uh k
mix uh b and d
uh through the algorithm that uh
leonard uh talked about in the previous
talk
uh and the conditions uh for solving
this that we need
is that
the number of observed uh variables n
is
sufficiently
large
with respect to
the total degree total
sorry the maximum total degree
in the graph
so uh so so so delta is
uh the maximum in plus out degree
this is somewhat uh
excluding uh the confounding variable u
we're just looking at the observed uh
graph
um so so we need something like delta to
the power of four times three k minus
three and the three k minus three you
can guess
uh comes out of uh what's needed for
um the mix prod algorithm yes
it's necessary for our method uh we
don't know that it's necessary
uh you know as as a condition on
identifiability
and that's actually you know one of the
open problems that that one can think of
can you come up with an algorithm that
depends only on the indegree because
indeed
uh i think
in your talk you you relate it to the in
degree that seems to be the right
parameter the in degree and uh but we
need the n plus out degree here
um
uh for a reason that will become clear
shortly
uh and this is the sample sizes that we
get so so this follows from from the
result on on
uh mix uh prod
which is here
on mixed prod
so you see that it's it's not
the the the main differences
is that uh you get this extra
exponential in k times uh
the degree squared
uh
in comparison with uh with what mix
prods uh gives us
um
okay so um
let me
i'll explain this very briefly and i
tried not to get into too many technical
details so i'm actually going to gloss
over some some of the details um not
everything is
is
completely accurate in what i'm
uh telling you here
um
so
um
the reduction
uh
depends crucially on the notion
uh called the markov boundary of a of a
variable v
so what is the markov boundary of v
it's uh the union
of uh the parents of v so so so these
are nodes that have edges coming into v
uh
the children of v
which are the nodes with uh edges from v
to
to that
node
and the parents of the children of v
excluding v
so so so so all so the union of these
three sets of nodes is the markov
boundary of v
and what we need uh this is where
uh the
uh
the
bound on the size of the graph comes
from
uh we we need uh uh three k minus three
variables that have mutually disjoint
markov boundaries so so here is here is
a particular example
uh it's pretty much the network i showed
you before except that we made a mistake
there so this edge had to be removed
instead of
fixing the
[Music]
you know
fixing the figure which i don't know how
to do
um
so uh so so you see here uh the blue red
uh
uh green and orange nodes are are these
uh
uh three k are these variables that have
mutually disjoint markov boundary so uh
the markov boundaries are indicated by
the same color as
uh the node so for instance this is the
marco
these nodes are the markov boundary of
v1 v1 doesn't have any parents but it
has a child and the child has a parent
and and that's the markov boundary um
here we have a markov boundary that
includes a parent and a child the child
doesn't have any parents so
um
so uh i don't think we have an example
here that has like
notes from all three sets
but but you see these are four micro
boundaries and they're mutually disjoint
so
um
assuming four is at least three k minus
three
uh
what does that
what
two is fine
yeah i guess uh then then we're good to
go
um
now you'll notice that the chosen
uh nodes the these these these nodes
they are
mutually independent
conditional on you
and on an assignment of values to uh all
these markov boundaries
so so so if we fix the values of of all
of these nodes
sort of almost all the network in this
case um
uh if we fix these values then then then
the colored uh nodes become uh mutually
independent and and we also fix you
so uh this is uh what we're going to do
um
in a nutshell uh
we will do something
which is called a run and we'll do it
many times a run
is basically
uh assigning values to the markov
boundaries or or sometimes it will be
just to the parents but
right now uh think of assigning values
uh to the nodes in the markov boundaries
conditioned on that
we get a uh a mixture of product
distributions on uh the chosen nodes
right because now uh they're independent
conditioned on u u takes values in one
through k uh we we get a a
mixture of product distributions
that's something we can learn from the
sample set
assuming the you know the particular
assignment that that we have appeared in
the sample set which which will make
sure
happens uh because we take a big enough
sample that it happens sufficiently many
times
and and then we we just get uh
these particular conditional uh
probabilities of of these nodes uh are
now uh recovered
so so so we know how
uh u affects the distribution of these
nodes
conditioned on the assignment to the
markov boundaries
now we're going to do this for uh
um
many different assignments
you know for all possible assignments
for instance
uh we'll we'll do we'll not do exactly
that but but for now think of of of this
this thing so so you know we'll we'll
make all possible assignments to to the
mark of uh boundaries uh
and
uh now we we get you know for every
assignment to the markov boundary we get
uh uh the the distributions of each of
these nodes
uh now there's one tiny little problem
is that
um
[Music]
the labeling of u
is invariant of permutations
so we need to align these runs
uh we we we need to align them in the
sense that we want
uh you to have the same permutation in
all of the results that we have so
that's one thing that one one
uh
uh serious thing that we need to do is
we need to make sure that we can align
all the runs
the other thing that we need to do is
okay we've recovered you know these
particular
nodes but we have like a bigger network
um
we want to recover uh the distributions
uh for all of the nodes and and in fact
we want to recover um the distribution
of each node not conditional on its
markov boundary but conditional on its
parents only
that's that's what defines the model so
so we so we need to recover the
probability of v conditional on u and
the uh assignment to the parent set of v
for all the nodes you
and for this we also need some procedure
which we call bayesian unzipping
so uh how much time do i have left
uh okay i'll i'll go over these uh
two
uh procedures briefly
uh by the way uh if you haven't realized
that earlier uh pa is the parent's head
and ch is the children set
um i guess i forgot i had that here
uh okay so um
so in order to do all this
uh we need a good collection
of runs
and a good collection of runs is a set
of runs a collection of rounds that are
alignable
and
um
that
will enable this bayesian unzipping
later so what do we need uh first of all
when are when are two runs alignable so
so there could be many many ways to
align runs but
uh here's one way
if if one of the independent uh of the
conditionally independent uh um vis
uh has
uh
the same
uh
uh sequence of of of
distributions uh probability v i given u
equals j
uh and we're assuming that these
distributions are
these probabilities are all distinct
then then obviously you can align
because um
uh
if
if if the if the
permutations are different
uh you will get the same value for
different values of u and then you can
determine a permutation
you you you ca you can permute uh one of
the two outcomes in a way that is
consistent with the other outcome
so so this is the alignment that that we
use
and we need a collection of runs
that uh can all be aligned together
now what this means is uh uh you can
just think of
the graph on runs
where
uh
there's an edge if the two rounds are
alignable if they have one variable that
that we can align with
so this graph has to be connected the
the the entire collection has uh to be a
connected graph um
with these edges
and then everything is alignable
now
the other thing that we have is that
each of the runs has at least three k
minus three independent variables
conditional on the assignment of values
to the markov boundaries of these
variables
which is part of the definition of the
run
and we also need that
every observed variable v in the graph
in total
and every assignment to the parents of v
is a cov is covered by at least one run
in the collection
so so so that's the the third main thing
that we have because of course if we
don't have it we don't get any
information on it
and then we need some uh additional
technical conditions that i won't go
into because i won't uh give you the
entire analysis uh including the
technical details so so so there are
some other
uh
more minor connections uh minor
conditions that are needed in order to
get the performance guarantees that that
that we are claiming
uh covered means that
v is included in the independent set and
the particular assignment to the parents
of v is
a
part of this run
okay
now how do we construct such a good
collection of runs
so here is how we do that
we start
with with these three k minus three
uh nodes that have mutually disjoint
markov boundaries
and we make some assignment to these
markov boundaries
and this is going to be the base run i
think in our paper we we had a different
name for it but
this is a simpler thing
it's it's just the baseline for all the
other runs so so so what we're going to
do is we're going to uh make sure that
all the other runs are alignable to this
run
so then they're all reliable
um now the other runs uh simply modify
this base run so how how do we
um
uh how do we
do the other runs
um so
uh first of all
uh for every
[Music]
uh
variable in this set v1 through v3k
minus
three we have a run that is identical to
the base run
or we have runs that are identical to
the base run except that for this
particular variable we change
its markov boundary
because we want to enumerate over all
the possible
uh parents at least uh so we enumerate
over all the possible assignments to the
markov boundary for every variable
uh independently and of course these
runs are alignable because there are
other variables that haven't changed
their markov boundary there in fact
they're alignable through many different
variables all of them except for one
now for all the other nodes
so so so there there are nodes in in the
in the network that are not these three
k minus three
special nodes
uh what we do
is
we we also and and for every assignment
to the parents of of the node v so for
every possible assignment
we generate
another run
and how is this run generated there
there are two
uh possibilities
some v's are included in the markov
boundary of one of the variables v on of
course not more than one because these
markov boundaries are disjoint
so if if a node is included in the
markov boundary of v i we just replace v
i by v
because of the definition of the markov
boundary we're guaranteed that the other
vjs are not parents of the are not
parents of this node and are not
children of this note
uh
and and we we we just assign
uh
make our assignment to the parents and
and and the rest of the assignments are
inherited from from uh from the base run
so that's what happens for for v that's
in one of the markov boundaries if v is
not in in uh um in in one of the markov
boundaries uh here otherwise uh we just
add this node
uh to um
our set of nodes so we'll have three k
minus two nodes instead of three k minus
three we can still run the
mixture of product distributions
algorithm
and we assign to its parents uh uh
the the values that we want and all the
rest of the the rest of the assignment
is is again inherited from
uh from uh uh the base run so so so this
is a good call this is how we construct
a good collection of runs
and then we we we uh solve all of these
runs using the mix prod
and now we're left with uh this bayesian
unzipping uh
um
um
task so so so what what is the bayesian
unzipping task
uh
generally except for you know
exceptional nodes that we only assign to
the parents
what we have is uh we we have the
distribution the entire distribution of
each node conditioned on you and on its
marker boundary
uh and and they're all aligned so so
it's all the same permutation on you
we have one interpretation for the
values of u uh now what we really want
is uh are these distributions for all
the nodes v because that's the model
uh that we want to recover
um
so so we're going to use this uh uh
formula this is really the definition of
conditional probability
so um for any assignment to the markov
boundary
uh
say the probability that uh v equals one
given
and and the markov boundary has this
value conditioned on you
uh
sorry the the probability that v was one
conditioned on you and the markov
boundary is this ratio
obviously
and now
this value
this you see we have these kinds of
values here and here this is of course
just 1 minus this uh so we have these
kinds of values and these kinds of
values factor nicely
into
uh
you know a product of three
probabilities
uh one of them is the thing that we want
it's this blue blue thing
now the orange part
it's the
probability of the markov bounty
excluding the children
conditioned on u
is independent of v
so uh of of the value of v so so when
you plug it into this ratio it just
cancels
and we're left with with with the uh
blue and green
terms
and the nice thing is that the the green
term
actually factors into
um
products over the children
of v
and these can be recovered
inductively
uh
in reverse topological order so so we
look at we look at the graph we we scan
it in reverse topological order and we
first
[Music]
can can solve all the sinks they don't
have any children so this term doesn't
exist given the solution to the children
we can recover their parents and so
forth so uh so uh this this inductive
process eventually recovers everything
and this is uh what we call bayesian
unzipping
okay here for some final remarks
on this
um
so uh uh the markov boundary the size of
the markov boundary is polynomial in
this max degree
uh and therefore
uh the number of uh nodes needed is is
three k minus three times uh a
polynomial in in the
max degree
in some special cases we can do better
than this uh for instance the uh mixture
of uh uh markov chains that i showed
in the beginning uh we we can do better
than than what this bound
uh
because you you can just take the odd
and even
nodes uh as as your
independent said
um
as i mentioned the case of
observables over larger domain reduces
to the zero one case
um
the zeta informative condition
is meant to
guarantee that all the product
distribution instances that we produce
are
zeta separated
so that's why it's a stronger condition
and
it seems like a strong condition but
it's fairly mild compared to anything
that
people
um used in past literature on special
cases
of this problem
and of course there are these uh
you know
obvious questions of uh better sample
size uh you know better computation time
uh as you mentioned
we're not sure that the dependence on on
the out degree should be there for
instance
and i have remarks beyond the final
remarks
uh just one one thing
so if you combine our two talks what we
showed is a two-step reduction from
mix b and d to mix prod to mix iid
so identifying uh
now it turns out this mix iid problem
seems really stupid it's like a mixture
of binomial distributions right that's
what you want to learn turns out that
it's a remarkably powerful uh tool that
uh can solve lots of different problems
so uh here we showed how it solves the
mixed b and d problem uh in in our
previous work we we showed how to reduce
identification of topic models to mix
iid
uh there is some other work uh
for
instance the kim ital paper i think that
leonard mentioned
reduces uh the problem of inferring
population histories to mix iid
there's some work on network evaluation
that reduces to mix iid so so so this
very simple problem seems to be a rather
powerful tool and of course um maybe
there are other applications to it
uh so that's it
in the gaussian case this morning so
the idea is you have you know some
linear structural equations
that you assume are also gaussian
and that's the
connections between that
binary
version of the result
i don't know that'd be interesting to
kind of have a look at
um
similar
this question but it's a good question
it's a good
uh so we don't know about the galaxy
case
okay thank you all we have lunch